يلجا الكثيرون الى تناول ادويه النوم بشكل
منتظم للحصول على قسط كافي من الراحه لكن
من المثير القلق ان مات تناوله قد يجعلك
اكثر عرضه للاصابه باعراض مرتبطه بالتدهور
المعرفي المستمر دراسه جديده استمرت تسع
سنوات وجدت ان تناول اقراص النوم بانتظام
يمكن ان يزيد من مخاطر الاصابه بالخرف
بنسبه هائله تصل الى 79% اوضح فريق البحث
عن النوع وكميه الدواء قد يكونان عاملين
في تفسير هذا الخطر العالم
شهدت السنوات الاخيره زياده في نسبه
الاشخاص الذين يعانون من الارق في مختلف
دول العالم الارق هو احد اكثر اضطرابات
النوم شيوعا حيث يصيب ما بين 10 الى 30%
من سكان العالم وفقا لما ذكرته المكتب
الوطني للطب تصل النسبه في بعض البلدان
الى 50 وستين في المئه يصيب الارق النساء
اكثر من الرجال بنسبه 40% وينتشر عند كبار
السن والاشخاص الذين يعانون من مشاكل صحيه
او اضطرابات نفسيه او عقليه ويصيب اكثر
ذوي الدخل المنخفض تشير الدراسات الى ان
الارقى نوعان الارق المؤقت الذي يصيب
الاشخاص لفتره قصيره والارق المزمن لفترات
متقطعه ويستمر الى بضعه اسابيع تعزى
الاسباب الى التغيرات المجتمعيه لاسيما
انشغال الناس بالتكنولوجيا وضغوط العمل
اضافه الى زياده معدلات السمنه ومرض كما
تشير الدراسات الى ان الارقى قد يكون
وراثيا حيث ان حوالي 35% من المصابين
لديهم تاريخ عائلي في هذا الصدد
[موسيقى]
على كل من ابو ظبي ينضم للناس شر النوم
دكتور هادي جرداق هادي الدكتور هادي اهلا
بك معنا في صباح العربيه الى اي بالفعل
الى اي مدى تناول ادويه النوم بانتظام
نتحدث عن الانتظام في تناولها يرفع خطر
الاصابه بالخرافه والدراسه تقول 79% يعني
نتيجه نسبه كبيره جدا بحسب الدراسه
صباح الخير بالفعل موضوع شيب
بدي ننوه بشغلتين في عده انواع من ادويه
النوم في دوره برهن 100% انه بيزيد من
حدوث او القرف
عند الاشخاص وهن ادويه البنزود بيتزا يعني
الفاليوم ومشابه هذا ادويه تستعمل عاده
معمل الاطباء بيستعملوها لتخفيف الضغوط
النفسيه في اشخاص بيستعملوها للنوم وهايدي
نوع من الادويه يلي ثبت
انا بتحدث الزهايمر بدون اي شك في ادويه
النوم الاخرى يلي نستعملها نحن كاطباء نوم
اللي هي من عائله
الزلفدام والزولبيكون اسماء غريبه شوي
نستعملها فقط للنوم وبتحدث قرف انما لما
تتوقف
شخص عنده هذا مشاكل
بحب اقول انه نحن كاطباء منجرب ما نستعمل
ادويه النوم انما اذا استعملناها
رواجيز بسيطه لندخل الشخص بالروتين
الايجابي
دكتور هادي صحيفه اكسبرس تقول ان اصحاب
البشره البيضاء لديهم مخاطر اعلى للاصابه
بالخرف عند تناول الادويه النوم نم ما
العلاقه بين لون البشره وادويه النوم
والاصابه بالخرف
[موسيقى]
اذا عنده ارض
اكبر لانه يصير معه خلف اذا تناول
هالادويه هذه ملاحظه مثل ما منلاحظ انه
ادويه الضغط عند البشره السمراء في ادويه
ما بتشتغل من هالعائله
هذه ملاحظه
لانما بالاجمال بتزيد عن كل الاشخاص بتزيد
اثر احتمال حدوث
الزهايمر عند كل الاشخاص انما اكثر اصحاب
البشره البيضاء تحدث عندهم
وكميه الدواء دواء النوم يا دكتور يلاقي
قد يكونان بالفعل العاملين في رفع خطر هذه
الاصابه
كلنا بنقطع بمراحل عدم النوم او قله النوم
او الارق بين من ورا ضغوطنا النفسيه شغل
العائله الى اخره كيف نتعاطى معها هي اللي
بتختلف في اشخاص بيلجاوا للادويه كوسيله
مستمره ومستدامه لمعالجتها المشكله الخطا
الشائع يلي بصير عند الاشخاص نحن ما عنا
مشكله اذا استعملناها لفتره وجيزه اسبوع
لنرجع للروتين لنرجع لطريقه النوم السليم
ونوقفها هذه ما في عنا مشكله فيها انما
المشكله انه اذا كان الشخص معتمد عليها
بشكل دائم هون الخطر فبقى نحن كاطباء نوم
قبل ما نلجا للادويه بنخلي المريض يلتزم
بعده امور تخليه ينام بشكل فعال مثل
ابتعاد عن الهواتف الذكيه والشاشات تخفيف
من الكافيين وكل الامور يلي هي ممكن تهدف
الدماغ ممارسه الرياضه ان تكون نظام نوم
ثابت منين بذات الوقت ونسحب زيت الوقت
غرفه النوم تكون سليمه هادئه مظلمه بارده
والى ما هنالك كل هالامور هي اساس هي
بتعالج الارق ب 80% من الوقت فقط بعشرين
بالميه منلجا لفتره وجيزه من الادويه وهذه
ما فيها ضرر والاشخاص اللي تمدين على
هالادويه فتره بقدر اقول لهم انه اذا
توجهوا لطبيب لانهم يقدر هو وياهم بمساعده
بعضهم انه يتخلصوا من هالعاده العاطله
ويمنعه تدهور حالتهم والوصول الى
الالزهايمر لا سمح الله طيب دكتور هادي
يعني هلا احنا عم نحكي عن نفس المرض لما
بنقول الزهايمر مع خرف ولا في فرق بينهم
وادويه النوم لمن تصيب بدرجه الاولى
نسميه على هالاسم بالنتيجه تدهور الحاله
الفكريه عند الشخص وبتؤدي
لعدم عدم معرفه الاشخاص وعدم التدهور
مستمر
شو يعني الزايمر بس كانه كان في فرق
بيقولوا تفرقه بين ديمنشيال هو الخرف او
الزهايمر يعني هل في خط فاصل بينهم وكنا
نتحدث عن ادويه النوم وماذا الزهايمر ام
ديفينتشيا
زمان شهيه وحده من عوارض
الخرفيه تاخر الفكر وبنقدر نقدر نستعملها
بشكل
تماما هو ذاته
مرض متكامل اهم معارض
ادراك عدم الادره على على نقدر نقول انه
هي نفس الشيء
ونقدر نقول انه استعمال هالادويه بشكل
مزمن عم بيؤدينا
لهالاتجاه شكرا جزيلا لك من ابوظبي
استشاري نوم دكتور هادي جرد